More representations of God the father.
I liked these representations.
I liked the triangle idea.
I mean I don't know why God
is wearing a triangular hat.
It's kind of a strange fashion choice,
but I think it's associated with the
idea of the pyramid and I think that's
associated with the idea of the hierarchy
of authority and I think that's why
the Egyptians put their
pharaohs inside pyramids.
I know there's more to it than that,
but I think some of that has to do
with the notion of this hierarchical
structure and you see this now
that's speculative obviously,
and I don't want to make too much of it,
but,
but I can't help but think
that there's something to that.
See that's on the back of
the American dollar bill.
I like that a lot.
That's like the eye of
horus from the Egyptians.
And so the idea here is something like
at the top of the hierarchy is something
that is no longer part of the hierarchy.
Right?
So if you move up the hierarchy enough,
what happens is that you develop the
ability as a consequence of moving up that
hierarchy to be detached enough from
the hierarchy so you're no longer really
part of it and so that you can move
in all sorts of different hierarchies.
And the thing,
the idea here is that the thing that
you're really developing the capacity to
pay attention,
and I would say from a,
from a mythological perspective,
the one thing that seems to compete
with the idea of the spoken word as the,
as the source of the extraction
of habitable order from
chaos is the eye is the
capacity to pay attention.
So Marduk,
for example,
the Mesopotamian Creator,
God who,
who,
who emerged in the hierarchy
of Mesopotamian gods and
came out at the top right?
He was the victor of the gods.
He had eyes all the way around his head
and he could speak magic words and I
really liked that.
I really liked that idea.
And the Egyptians develop that
idea too because they're god.
Horus was the eye.
Everyone knows the eye of horus,
that that that image is so
compelling that we still know about.
Everybody has seen the eye of horus
with a really open pupil and what the
Egyptians learned was that the open I
was what revivified the dead's society.
That's so smart.
So what do you do if
your life isn't in order?
Bloody well,
pay attention not isn't
the same as thinking.
It's a different process.
Paying attention thinking is like the
imposition of structure in some sense.
I know I'm over simplifying,
but paying attention to something like
watching for what you don't know and so
like one of the things that
I often recommend to my
clinical clients if they're
having trouble with a
family member is number one,
shut up.
Don't tell them anything about yourself.
Just and I don't mean in a rude way,
it's just like no more
personal information.
Number two,
watch them like a hawk and listen.
And if you do that long enough,
they will tell you exactly what they're
up to and they will also tell you who
they think you are and then you'll
be shocked because they think you're
something generally speaking,
that's not like what you are
at all and when they tell you,
it's like a revelation to both of you,
but attention is an unbelievably
powerful force and you see this in
psychotherapy to because a lot of
what you do and in any repairative
relationship is really pay
attention to the other person.
Pay attention and listen and that would
not believe what people will tell you or
reveal to you if you watch them as if
you want to know instead of watching them
so that you'll have your
prejudices reinforced.
That's usually how people interact.
It's like,
I want to keep thinking about you the
way I'm thinking about you and so I'm
going to filter out anything
that disproves my theory.
That's not what I'm talking about at all.
It's like I'm going to watch you
and figure out what you're up to.
Not in a rude way.
None of that.
I just want to see what's
there and that'll be good
for you probably and also be
good for me.
And so well,
so that's the idea that,
you know,
climbing up a hierarchy of authority
can give you vision and that vision can
transcend the actual hierarchy.
And I think that's also,
I think that's also the,
uh,
that's the metaphysical space that an
artist occupies because artists really
aren't in a hierarchy
there outside of higher.
He's,
you've watched the lion king,
most of you.
Yeah.
That's zoo,
you know the little bird,
that's the eye of the king
as the same thing there.
So,
and that's,
that's echoed in this idea as well.
So,
so,
well,
that's some more,
more ideas of hierarchy.
Same idea.
This is right.
Gold,
silver,
bronze.
Why gold gold as the sun gold is pure,
right?
And so the idea is that the thing
that's at the top of the hierarchy is
incorruptible because gold
doesn't mix with anything else,
right?
It's this sort of metal that
doesn't ever become corrupted.
It's a noble metal.
It doesn't become corrupted.
And so it shines like the sun and it's
associated with whatsoever at the top of
the hierarchy and the goal,
the gold medal is a disc like the sun,
and it's awarded to those people who've,
who've occupied the top position and
who are manifestations of the ideal.
And here,
here's,
I'll tell you a quick story.
So imagine that you're
watching an Olympic contest.
I found this happens to me very often
with gymnastics because of a gymnast.
So absolutely unbelievable.
You know,
so you go,
you watch a gymnastic performance and uh,
the person's out there
bouncing around like,
you know,
you can't even imagine doing it.
There are so perfect at it.
So you see this person,
they're going through this routine,
they're just absolutely
spectacular and flawless added.
You know,
at the end they stop and everybody claps
and they're all excited to see what a
human being can do.
And that's why we're in the audience
watching because we want to see what a
human being can do.
And the judges go like nine point eight,
nine point eight,
nine point eight.
Everybody's thrilled.
And then the next contestant
comes out and it's like,
well,
they're just basically screwed,
right?
It's like this person came
out there and was perfect.
How are you going to top that?
That's an interesting question because
this is a representation of what you do
to top perfection itself
and you can do it.
And here's how you do it.
And you know this even though
you don't know you know it.
So let's say the next contestant comes
out and they're kind of shaky because
it's like,
oh man,
the bar has been raised high.
So what they do is they put themselves
right on the edge of chaos and you can
tell by watching them that they are
one bloody fraction of a second from
catastrophe.
There are pushing themselves farther than
they've ever gone in the direction of
their perfection.
And everyone in the room is so tense,
they can hardly stand it,
right?
You could hear a pin drop and that person
is flipping around and they're just,
it's just right on the
edge of catastrophe.
And at the end they go like this,
you know?
And there's that gesture that the
triumph that goes along with that,
and everybody rises in one instance
and just collapse like mad.
It's like,
well,
why?
What are you doing?
What are you doing when you're doing that?
Right?
You can't even help it.
It grabs you right in the core of your
being and you stand up and it's an act of
worship.
That's what it is.
And you saw someone go beyond their
perfection into the domain of chaos and
establish order right in front of your
eyes and you're so thrilled about that.
You know you're happy to be alive and
everyone's celebrating it all at the same
time.
And it's an absolutely amazing thing.
And that's what.
Well,
sometimes that's what this represents.
And sometimes that's what this represents.
And that's what we're trying to get at
that because that's at the pinnacle of
the hierarchy,
right?
Not only are you doing
what you should be doing,
but you're doing it in
a way that increases the
probability that you'll do it
better the next time you do it.
And then you could say,
here's another thing to think
about along the same lines,
and I know we haven't
gotten to Adam and eve.
Yes,
you tell your kids to play fair,
right?
You say it's not him.
It's not whether or not you win.
It's how you play the game.
And you say that you don't
really know what you mean.
You feel kind of stupid saying it even
though you know it's true and your kid
looks at you like there's something wrong
with you because he doesn't know what
you're talking about either,
but you know it's true.
And so here's why it's true.
Life isn't a game.
It's a set of games.
And the rule is never sacrificed victory
across the set of games for victory in
one game.
Right?
And that's what it means to play properly.
You want to play so that
people keep inviting you to
play because that's how you
win,
right?
You win by being invited to play
the largest possible array of games.
And the way you do that is by manifesting
the fact that you can play in a
reciprocal manner every time you play.
Even if there's victory at stake and
that's what makes you successful across
time and we all know that and
we even tell our kids that,
but we don't know that we know it.
And so we're not adapting ourselves
to the game and victory in the game.
We're adapting ourselves to the metagame
and victory across the set of all
possible games.
And that's what that.
Well,
that's exactly what,
as far as I can tell,
that's exactly what this
is aiming at to that.
That's the same idea that there's,
that there's a transit,
there's a mode of being that
transcends the particularities of this,
of the localized contest.
That's the other way to think about it.
And to act morally is not to win today's
contest at the expense of the rest of
possible contests.
And again,
I don't see that as
something that's arbitrary.
It's not relativistic.
There's an absolute moral is
an absolute moral stance there.
And everyone recognizes it.
And,
and I also think it's the key to success.
And I would also say it's very
much akin in a strange way,
like the,
uh,
the,
the person who is the master at being
invited to play the largest possible
games,
number of games is also the same
person I haven't quite figured out.
The precise relationship between these
two is also the same person that goes out
forthrightly to conquer the unknown
before it presents itself as the enemy at
the door.
They're the same thing.
Now I don't,
I can't have him figured.
Well why that is exactly.
But,
but well,
I'll figure it out eventually.
And when I do,
I'll tell you if you're interested.
So okay.
So here's some other no ideas of,
of,
of God as,
as,
as hierarchical authority figures.
So strip the religious preconceptions off
what you observe and just look at what
you see.
Well look,
there's primate looking upward at
dominant figure that that's what you see
there.
Now,
if it's very interestingly symbolically
represented because you have God the
father there with the cross.
And I think what that
means as far as I can tell,
is that there's a recognition there in
the image that the person who's most
dominant is the one who's or
the most has the most authority,
is the one who's voluntarily
accepted the suffering.
That's part of being.
And that's what that picture represents.
It's like the authority holds that says
this is what you have to accept and
that,
that trend fix the viewer because of the.
Because of the fact that it's true.
And you think,
well,
is that true?
Okay,
well think about it this way.
Do you like brave people are cowards?
Well,
that,
that's pretty straightforward.
And what's the ultimate act of bravery?
It's to come to terms with the fact
that you're mortal unlimited and to live
forthrightly regardless.
Well,
obviously that's at the core of what's
of what's admirable and why would we
presume that that's not the case.
We act as if that's the case.
It's what everyone dreams
and wishes that they could.
They could do.
I mean,
assuming that you know,
you've dispensed with the idea
that you're going to be a mortal.
I suppose that might be worth wishing
for two or or perhaps not immortal is a
very long time,
but you certainly want
this and that image says,
well this is what you
should be and you know,
we've got that same opening into the
sky going on in that image that I showed
you before.
It's like this is a transcendent truth
that constantly read manifests itself
across time and space and young would
say it's built into your psyche that
image.
Now you know,
there are elements of it that
are culturally constructed.
It wouldn't necessarily
have to be the cross,
although the cross is a very old symbol.
It's far older than than it's used in,
in Christianity and
it's been used in many,
many religious representations,
but that Echo is the
sole echoes with that,
you know,
and
well,
and then there's Moses up there on the,
on the mountain receiving the,
the,
the law and so we'll talk a lot more
about that when we get the exodus.
But if.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If we get to exodus,
so.
Well look,
where does it happen?
Well,
on a mountain,
well that's a pyramid.
That's op,
right?
That's optics up.
It's,
it's up in the stratosphere,
it's up in the sky where,
where you'll look upward.
Okay,
and then so what's happening to Moses?
Well,
here,
here's a bit of a clue
as far as I can tell.
I figured this out partly again by
reading jumped piaget because one of the
things that Piaget said about kids was
that they first learned to play a game,
but they don't know what the rules are.
Meaning that if you have
a bunch of kids together,
they can play a game.
But if you take one of the kids
out of the game when they're young,
say six and you say what the rules are,
what are the rules?
They can only sort of
give you a representation.
So you take 60 year old one and he'll
tell you some of the rules and six year
old to will tell you different rules.
And,
and you know,
six year old three will
tell you different rules,
but if you put them all
together they can play.
So they have the knowledge embodied
either individually or in the group.
The knowledge is there to be extracted,
well then they get a little older,
they can extract the rules and then they
started to play by the rules and then
Piaget's last step was,
well,
it doesn't just the kids play by the
rules is that they learned that they can
make the rules and he thought
about that as moral progression.
First you can play,
then you can play by the rules.
Then you learn maybe because he
didn't think everyone learned this,
that you're actually
the master of the rules.
That doesn't mean the rules are arbitrary,
but it means that you can be
the generator of the roof.
That's assuming that you knew how to play
the game and he thought about that as
a moral moral progression
and then I thought,
well that's exactly what happened to Moses
and the story of exodus because Moses
is out there leading all those Israelites
around and like they don't have a law.
They don't have a law giver.
They have a tradition and
they're all like crabby because,
well they're in the desert.
It's like they're in a tyranny,
but now they're in a desert.
It's like that's no improvement,
so they're,
they're really getting pretty bitchy
about it and so they're worshiping false
idols and having one catastrophe after
another and they get Moses to judge their
conflicts and so he does that for God
only knows how long forever crabby
Israelites come to
Moses and bitch at them.
It's like,
wow,
he did this,
and she did that and and so then he has
to figure out how to make peace and he
does that so long that one of his,
I think it's his father in law,
tells him he has to stop doing it
because he's going to exhaust himself.
Well.
Then you think,
well,
what's happening?
Well,
and I'm not assuming that this is
a like a literal historical story.
I think again,
it's a condensation well,
any group has a set of customers
just like a wolf pack does,
and so then the customers are being
manifest in someone who's a genius is
watching and thinking,
okay,
well what's the rule in this situation?
What's the rule of this situation?
What's the rule in this situation?
And then in his imagination,
the rules turn into a hierarchy and then
he goes up on the mountain and he goes
back and he thinks,
oh my God,
here's the rules that we've
been living by all this time.
And that's the revelation
of the commandments.
Well,
and you think,
well,
how else could it be?
I think the rules came first
and obeying them came second.
So I know the rules come first,
sorry.
The actions come first.
The,
the obeying them comes first and then
you figure out what everybody's up to and
you say,
hey look,
this is what you've been up to all along.
And everybody goes,
Oh yeah,
that seems to make sense.
And if it didn't,
who would follow them?
No one was going to follow them.
If they don't match what's already there,
you just think about that as unjust.
And so that's,
that's portrayed here as
a cataclysmic human event.
It's like,
Oh my God,
we've been chimpanzees and we've been
in this hierarchy of authority for so
long.
We have no idea what we were doing.
And all of a sudden,
poof.
It burst into revelatory consciousness.
And we could say,
here is the law,
and you say,
well,
is it given by God?
Well,
hey,
it depends on what you mean by God.
We could start with that presupposition,
but it's not like it
just came out of nowhere.
It took,
and this is something else Nicha observed.
So interestingly,
and he said,
you know that a moral revelation was
the consequence of a tremendously long
process of initial construction and then
formulation thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of years of custom
of building custom before you get the
revelation of the articulated law.
And that's a description of the
pattern that works and let's say,
well,
what's the pattern that works?
It's the game that you can play with
everybody else day after day with no
degeneration.
And that's another thing piaget figured
out that so brilliant and that's his
idea of the equilibrated state.
It's,
it's an extension of a manual counts idea
about the universal maximum right act
in a way so that each action
could become a universal rule.
That was con,
fundamental moral maximun
piaget put a twist on that.
He said,
no,
that's not exactly yet.
It's act in such a way that it works
for you now and next week and next month
and next year and 10 years
from now and so that,
well,
it's working for you.
It's also working for the people around
you and for the broader society and,
and,
and that's the equilla braided state,
and you could think about that as an
intimation of the Kingdom of the city,
of God on earth.
It's something like that and it's based
on this idea that a morality has to be
iterable and you know,
there's lots of,
there's been lots of
simulations online already,
artificial intelligence,
simulations of trading games,
right?
I mean,
the people who've been studying the
emergence of moral behavior say an
artificial intelligent systems
have already caught onto
the idea that one of the
crucial elements to the analysis
of morality is interability.
You can't play a
degenerating game because.
Because it degenerates,
like obviously you want to
play a game that had leased,
remained stable across time,
and God,
if you could really get your act together,
maybe it would slowly get better.
And of course that's what
you'd hope for your family.
Right?
That's what you're always
trying to do and less,
you're completely hell bent
on revenge and destruction.
It's like,
is there a way that we can continue to
play together that will make playing
together even better the next day.
But I will say something about it,
you know,
and I thought about this a lot,
so there is evidence that Ashkenazi Jews,
so those are Jews of European heritage,
have iqs that are about 15 points
higher than the population average.
So that's a lot 15 points.
It's about the average difference between
the typical high school student and
the typical state college student.
It's a lot.
And one of the things that means is,
so imagine there's two distributions and
that they overlap and that the Jewish
one is,
uh,
is the mean is 1:15.
So the whole distribution
has shifted to the right.
What that means is that if you
go up into the Higher Iq strata,
1:30,
1:45 way the hell up there,
that Jewish people are overwhelmingly
overrepresented at the high end of the ICU
distribution.
Now the price they pay for that is some
increased propensity for neurological
diseases that seems to be associated
in some sense with that heightened Iq.
Now,
you know,
the science on this isn't settled but,
but it,
it's reasonably solid,
you know,
given the standards of such things.
Okay,
so Jews are going to be our over
represented at the high end of cognitively
complex disciplines.
So then I would say,
and that's the case,
like they're way overrepresented among
like outstanding scientists and among
Nobel Prize winners and and so forth.
And so you know,
people look and they think,
well why are there a disproportionate
number of Jewish people in positions of
authority?
And they say,
well,
it must be a conspiracy.
You know,
it must be systemic in some sense.
It's like,
no,
it can be simply accounted for by that
relatively large ICU differential.
Now the next criticism would be,
well,
don't the Jews tend to lean left?
Well first you might say,
well,
you know,
given what happened in Nazi Germany to
the degree that that was right wing as we
discussed earlier,
that's the nationalism and ethnocentrism.
It's hardly surprising that they might,
you know,
in this historical period of time
tend to move towards the left,
but more importantly than that,
Iq is associated with trait,
openness and trade.
Openness is a strong predictor
predictor of political liberalism.
So,
and it's the strongest predictor
of political liberalism.
So,
you know,
it's very difficult.
So that's what I have to say about that.
It's like in the other
thing I would say is,
you know,
the fact that there's a population as
sub population of people who are much
smarter than average,
not on average,
right?
On average,
I've got to get that straight on average
is actually of great benefit to the
rest of us because why do
you want fewer geniuses?
Fewer people with Iq of 145 or 160.
That's and you know,
and it's no conspiracy that
puts people who are smarter,
higher up in competence hierarchies
because I accused the best predictor of
movement up in a complex
con competence hierarchy.
So there,
I've addressed the Jewish question.
It's like it's a confusion between
ethnicity and and ICU as far as I'm
concerned.
So I'll probably get like painted six
different shades of black for that answer,
but it's.
I've thought about a long time.
It's the best that I can manage.